in October 2015 we learned that Fox was  developing two x-men shows one of the  show's titled Legion is coming to FX and  now we know who it's going to star first  up is Dan Stevens best known for his  role on Downton Abbey he'll be playing  professor X's troubled son then there's  Aubrey Plaza who you probably recognize  as April Ludgate from parks and  recreation finally there's Jean smart  most recently seen in another FX show  Fargo in speaking of Fargo showrunner  Noah Hawley will also be taking the  reins of Legion production for the show  kicks off in March Fox's other x-men  show is titled Hellfire based on the  Hellfire Club featured in x-men first  class we don't know much about that one  yet but when we learn more or get more  details on Legion you'll hear about it  on gamespot